OLIVIA: So I'm Olivia.
I work at Fathom
Information Design.
We're over in Boston.
And we do-- a lot of our
work is in data visualization
and information design.
And we use processing
for that, which is what
we're going to be using today.
So processing is both a
community and development
environment and a
language to kind of make
it as simple as
possible to get up
and running with something
visual on the screen.
So you can use it for making 3D.
You can do what
we're going to do,
image processing,
kind of looking
at the pixel
information of images.
Or kind of pulling in data and
creating things based on that.
So do any of you guys
have an idea of what
you think of when you
hear image processing
or what that might be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OLIVIA: Yes.
Yes, so a lot of
it is about kind
of manipulating the
information that you get when
you kind of take a picture.
Usually, it's to enhance
it so whether that
means you're making
it more clear to be
able to kind of
analyze information
in there or in enhancing
it in an aesthetic way
kind of like with
Instagram or Snapchat.
So kind of doing
that through code
is what we're going to do today.
It uses a mix of math and
computer science so a lot of it
is these mathematical
functions that
manipulate the different pieces
of the image information.
And we're going to
use computer science
with processing to kind
of mix it all together
and create our filters.
So there are a lot of
different things you can do.
It can be as simple as kind
of enhancing the contrast.
So in this case, this
is a photo that's
taken underwater on the left.
And you can't
really see anything
so people have gone in and just
enhanced the contrast, which
usually means playing with the
values, the light and the dark
of the image to start to make
out the different shapes.
And then they can use it for
analysis or to put in a book.
Sometimes we take
images-- you guys
were building cameras
earlier using visible light,
x-rays are another
way of taking images,
but you're using x-rays
instead of the visible light,
the wavelengths.
And then, again, kind
of enhancing those
images so that we can find
different medical anomalies.
You can also use x-rays to
look at layers behind paint.
So a lot of times you might
hear a story about they found
that a person was in this
painting and then it got
painted over.
The way they know
that is through taking
these different
images and enhancing
the information in them.
And one that I think is really
cool is a lot of space images
that you see are mixes of image
data from different telescopes.
So this is actually
a combination
from three different telescopes.
I think the blue is
x-ray information,
the gold is information
from Hubble,
and then the red might be a
different x-ray telescope.
So kind of merging all of those
together and coloring them
in a certain way
so that people can
start to get scientific
knowledge from the photos.
And then there's also this
kind of cyclical process
of so now we have cameras that
are really good at recognizing
faces so that our pictures of
our family can be way better.
But the way we were
able to do that
is by looking at pictures
of faces and kind
of teaching the camera
what to look for.
So kind of using images
to enhance later images.
And what we're going
to focus on today
is manipulating the color
information of our photos
for purely aesthetic purposes.
So Instagram uses a set of
filters which really is just
a set of mathematical functions
that are applied to the image
information.
And then spit back out your
image with its new colors.
So in order for us to
be able to do this,
I'm going to talk a little bit
about the different ways you
might access the color
information of your photo.
And kind of how
computers see color.
You might have talked about this
a little bit with the cameras
earlier so it's
a good refresher.
But let's start with
a grayscale image.
So on the left is our
image of the baboon.
And when you have
a grayscale image,
everything is on
a range of black
to white that can be stored as
a number, usually zero to 255.
And then over here,
it's just kind
of plotting what
those values are.
So you start to get a sense
of how image information can
be seen as just sort of a set
of numbers, a set of values.
This is up close at like
one square of your image,
so again, every pixel
in a gray scale image
will have one value.
So it can be from zero for
black and 255 for white.
And then a color
image is usually just
like three layers
of that information.
So if you're looking at
an image in RGB mode,
which is pretty standard for
how digital cameras work,
usually how computers
are thinking about color
information, it's three layers
of those zero to 255 values.
But in this case, it's
like from black to pure red
or black to pure green
and black to pure blue.
And then we kind of
add those all together
with the correct weights, you'll
get your full color image.
So this is one way to start
pulling out the information
and playing with it.
So in processing, you'll
see in the filters
that sometimes people will go
through and for every pixel,
take out what is the
red, what is the green,
and what is the
blue of that pixel.
And then you can just
say OK, add 10 to red
and that will totally
change your image.
So this is just
an example of what
happens when you start playing
with the different RGB values.
And we'll see an example of a
different kind of color scheme
in a second.
So if this is my
original image over here,
I've started bumping up the
blue or taking down the red,
so the whole image
has this color shift.
But it also starts to manipulate
the lights and the dark
because in RGB mode, the
lightness and the darkness
of an image is tied to
the color of the image.
So sometimes you might want
to edit those separately.
And that's where HSB mode
is really helpful, so hue,
saturation, and brightness.
So you can also,
through processing,
take the color
information of your image,
but separate how bright
it is, what color it is,
and how intense that color is.
So in this case, what we're
looking at across here
is where someone has-- if
this is their original image,
they've shifted the hue.
So hue is the color you see.
But they haven't
changed the lightness
or the intensity of the color.
If we think of an apple
as red and this is also--
this is chalk, which
is also technically red
but it looks more
like pink because it
has a lower saturation.
So this is like when you have
a pure red versus something
that's lower saturation.
And then cherries are also red,
but they have a darker value.
So that's the brightness.
So again, pure red versus
something with a lot more black
in it.
So you can also think of this as
like if you were mixing colors
with paint, if it needs a lot
of white to create that color,
then it probably has
a lower saturation.
If you needed a lot of
black to make that color,
then it probably
has a lower value.
So here you can start
to play with your image
and say I want
everything to be darker,
but I want it to
stay the same color.
Or like with the
butterfly, I want
to like-- so like in this
case, the one on the right,
I changed just the color
but I didn't change any
of the saturation or the value.
So you can see how
these are equally bright
and this one in
the middle starts
to get more gray because as
I've manipulated the RGB values,
I've also manipulated
how light it is.
So now we can start to
make filters of our own.
And the filters that we have
kind of set up for you guys
to play through are--
these are some of them.
So there is this one, which
is kind of like posterization.
So a lot of the time if you want
to print something as a poster,
you kind of have to get it as
close as possible to like black
and white as opposed
to like having
all the range of gray values.
So kind of just messing
around and seeing what
happens when you
start to take out
those middle values of gray.
And then, also
manipulating the colors.
This one is not so much playing
with the color information,
but if you have your
image dimensions
and you want to add
something like a vignette
to it, being able to say, here
is where the center of my image
is and then how, based on that,
you can add a color on top.
And so adding this ring on top.
This one, it allows as you
click around the image,
it'll pick one color so this
is using like hue saturation
and brightness.
So it'll pick the hue and then
light up all the other pixels
with that hue and get rid of
the hue in all the other ones.
So kind of seeing how many
colors there are in an image
or being able to highlight
just the red pieces.
And then the last one is-- so
I don't know how many of you
guys have ever played
around with Photoshop,
but they have this thing
called blend modes, which
is what a lot that people use to
apply different colors on top.
And so that just says
if you put a color
on top, what's
the math that it's
taking with that color on top
and the image on the bottom.
And how it adds them together.
So this is trying to imitate
the overlay mode, which
just kind of taking
part of one color
and part of the other and then
spitting back out a new color.
So those are the different
filters we have today.
SPEAKER: Let's give Olivia
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]